PETE LEPAGE: Hey.
Welcome, everybody, to
another exciting
Chrome Apps Office Hours.
This week, we have a really
special show.
Paul and I decided that rather
than go into some really crazy
kind of deep topic right before
the holidays, we wanted
to just show you a bunch
of really cool stuff.
We wanted to just hang out with
you, answer some of your
questions, dive into some of
the things that you thought
might be interesting that we
thought have been interesting
in the last six months since
we launched Chrome Apps.
So with that, I'll let Paul say
hi and introduce yourself.
Paul, do you want
to say hi and--
PAUL KINLAN: Hi.
I'm Paul.
I'm based in London.
Yeah, and you're in Mountain
View today.
That's pretty cool.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
It's kind of neat.
Normally we do this.
I'm in New York.
Paul's in London.
This week, I'm in
Mountain View.
We have the illustrious
Louis Gray helping us
produce this event.
So kind of a fun way
to be doing things.
So let's start.
I want to show you a Chrome app
that I put together this
morning very special
for this week.
Because I just was thinking, as
I was on my way into work
this morning, I'm like, huh,
what's going on this week?
Well, I'm in Mountain View.
I've got to get a couple
of things done.
And I was like, oh, right.
There's this really cool event
happening this week.
So I decided I was going to sit
down and pull together a
real quick Chrome app.
So let's go to my screen.
I'm going to pull this guy up.
And this is a little
Chrome app.
You can pull this up in
the Chrome Web Store.
I'll post a link to this
in our post afterwards.
But just in case you were
curious how long it was until
the end of the world, until
December 21 at 11:11 UTC, we
are now two days, 18 hours, six
minutes, and 56 seconds--
oh, 55 seconds-- oh, 50-- oh--
anyways, you get point.
Until the end of the world.
And I feel fine.
PAUL KINLAN: Does it
do time zones?
PETE LEPAGE: So yes, that takes
into account time zones.
So same number of hours
left between us, Paul.
So if I don't see you
next week, Paul--
well, actually, our Chrome Apps
Office Hours next week
would happen to fall
on Christmas Day.
I don't plan on working.
So I won't see you next
week this time.
But I'll see you in the
new year as long as
this doesn't happen.
How does that sound?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Good.
I think it sounds good.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Well Paul, I know you had
a couple of apps that
you wanted to show.
I've got a couple more that
I want to talk about.
And we'll take your questions.
Louis, if we could put the
questions, the moderator link
up, so if people have questions
and they want to ask
questions, please post
your questions to
our moderator link.
And Paul and I will take
those as we go along
and take your questions.
So with that, Paul, I'll
pass it over to you.
And you can talk about a couple,
and then I'll come
back and do a couple more.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, cool.
So today is all about showing
you some cool things that have
been built with Chrome Apps.
Obviously, it's, not completely
public yet, in the
sense that normal consumers
can't re-download these
applications and install
them into Chrome.
But you can still do some
really cool stuff.
All of these are available
in the Web Store.
Most of these are already
available in the Web Store,
which I think was two weeks ago,
I think, where basically,
we just enabled it so that you
could actually upload these
and host them and get your
users to test the
applications.
And one of them which we can't
actually get installed just
yet is this news reader, which
we had actually built for
Google I/O. But there's
a lot of changes that
went on in the WebView.
Well, it wasn't even called
WebView at the time.
It was called the browser tag.
There were a lot of changes that
kind of were happening.
And we didn't have this great
situation of where we could go
off and show this application.
But in the past couple of weeks,
the WebView API has
settled down quite a bit.
And I want to show you
this application.
It's pretty cool.
PETE LEPAGE: So Paul, before you
go there, I want to just
touch on two little things that
you commented on that I
think are really important.
One, you can start uploading
your apps to
the Chrome Web Store.
So if you're building a Chrome
App today, you can upload it
to the Chrome Web Store.
But there are a couple of
restrictions on that, right?
PAUL KINLAN: You can't upload
experimental APIs just yet,
because-- well, you've
never been able to.
But you can't do that.
Identity doesn't work properly
and WebView doesn't work.
But they'll come out of
experimental soon.
And you'll be happy, and you'll
be able to upload.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
And then the other key thing is
that if I go search for one
of the apps that you've
uploaded, Paul--
actually, where--
Paul, are you on this
side of me or are--
you're on one side of me.
So here--
Paul-- that way.
If you upload it, users
can't find it.
They have to actually
go and know the URL.
And it's like Chrome Web
Store dot something,
dot something, dot--
really big--
hang on.
Let me make sure
I'm on screen--
really big long URL, slash
something, slash something.
So the best thing to do
if you want to share
these with your friends--
upload them, use a link
shortener, and give the
shortened link to
your friends.
So that way they can easily
go in and grab it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, exactly.
That's it.
Once we launch this fully,
you'll be able to search them,
and they'll be aggregated
properly inside the Web Store.
But right now, it's still
experimental.
We're still learning about how
to you, as developer, want to
interact with the Web Store,
and how users will want to
download the applications as
well, which I think we can
show more stuff in a later
episode [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: The only other
thing I want to point out for
folks who are watching today--
there are still a couple of bugs
around what's required
and what's not.
So it may say something's not
required when it actually is.
I think that's the way
most of the bugs are.
It'll tell you, oh,
it's not required.
You go to hit Publish, and
it comes back and says
[BUZZER SOUND], you've got
to go put this in.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, the flow is
not that great at the moment.
It will get better.
PETE LEPAGE: And we're
working on that.
So please make sure you tell us
about those kinds of things
if you do find them.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So should I show you
this application?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Let's have a look.
PAUL KINLAN: So this
is really cool.
I really like this application,
because you can
basically query Google News.
All this data's coming from
Google News, the RSS feed and
Atom feeds.
It's completely unofficial.
It's like an application
that you would
build as a normal developer.
But it's really cool because--
let's have a look at something
that's not-- shouldn't
[INAUDIBLE] the dark ages.
You can open up an article.
Then this opens up
the WebView.
And when the WebView
works, which--
something has happened.
It's not quite working
just yet.
PETE LEPAGE: Uh oh.
Damn it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so what would
happen normally is that
the actual content would come
into this application here and
be displayed.
And the really nice thing is if
you look on the left-hand
side, you'll see like a picture
of Nelson Mandela.
It's kind of like slightly
grayed out and blurred.
There we are.
It's loaded up.
It's pretty cool.
I think it's probably our
network connection's a little
bit crazy at the moment.
You can press Escape.
And you get out.
There's articles.
It's pretty cool.
Scroll down.
There's a whole lot of
really nice stuff.
And I'm going to tell you
about this image.
And these are all
remote images.
And I'll show you-- well,
I say I'll show you.
I'll tell you about a little
framework that we've built
which enables you to download
images that are hosted on the
web and store them in the
local HTML5 file cache.
PETE LEPAGE: Because you can't
just say, image with a source
equals something else or source
equals some remote server.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Exactly right.
So you can't do that.
But we've enabled it so you can,
in a way, a little bit.
And we've got a library that's
on GitHub as well.
And then you can do things like
filter by top stories,
and they work as well.
I really feel my network's
a little bit slow on this
machine at the moment.
Wow.
There we are.
Let's go back to that one.
So the good thing is, even if
I have not got an internet
connection and something's going
crazy, all the articles
and information is cached so
that it's all basically stored
in index db.
You query the categories for the
list of articles that you
want inside a particular one.
And then you can do nice things
like, for instance,
flip between different
countries, as well.
So if you're Spanish and you
want Spanish news, you'll go
off and query the Spanish
Google News sites.
So, yeah.
It's pretty cool.
It's pretty nice.
We've had it around since
Google I/O, at least.
But until WebView can start to
stabilize a little bit, I've
not pushed it too much.
But the source code is on our
GitHub project as well.
So you can go out and check
out how we've done
everything, as well.
So it's pretty cool.
PETE LEPAGE: And that's on the
GitHub Google Chrome slash
Chrome App Samples place?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Exactly right.
So let me--
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
PAUL KINLAN: I'll go
get it in a minute.
PETE LEPAGE: We can--
actually, Louis, if we can put
that lower third up on, there
should be the samples one.
So you should be able
to see it somewhere.
It should be, like, right
down about there.
So you can go see that.
PAUL KINLAN: So can I show
you guys something as
well about the code?
So this is the actual commit
that I did the other day,
which if I go full screen,
should make it a little bit
easier to read.
So this is the commit I did
the other day to the news
reader app.
And it's
googlechrome/newsreaderapp on GitHub.
So basically, it doesn't look
like I've done much.
But essentially, I've removed
a whole lot of code that we
normally use to actually go and
get the remote image from
the web, which is normally
a bit XML HTTP request.
We store it in the file system
using the file, the .js.
And there's actually quite a
lot of code just to do a
relatively small process.
So we've removed all this.
And there was a couple
of places it was in.
It was code that was duplicated
all over the place.
And we replaced it-- if we
get to the right place--
with this thing called RAL.
And basically it's a Resource
Asset Loader, which is a
project that we've written.
It's also on our
GitHub project.
I've enabled debug because I
want more information at the
back of it.
I do this thing called QStart.
And now what happens is,
whenever you add something to
the resource asset loader,
essentially what will happen
is it will go to say, well,
I need to go and
download this asset.
It will bring it in, cache it in
the local HTML file system,
and then you'll be able
to consistently
access it as well.
So--
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, interesting.
PAUL KINLAN: Every
time you ac--
PETE LEPAGE: Does it--
PAUL KINLAN: Every time you
access that image, it will go
and get it from the
file system.
It's got a whole lot of other
nice things about caching.
So there's cache headers that
say cache is only--
yeah.
So if it says cache is only for
24 hours, it'll cache it
for 24 hours.
But it will still use it
if you're offline.
The actual asset loader, as
well, is pretty cool.
And one of my colleagues,
Paul Lewis, did
all the work on this.
It's pretty cool, because
it detects when
you're online and offline.
And if you have requests for
images, like in the queue--
say, 100 requests--
and maybe something [INAUDIBLE]
to actually get to
a service to get the image.
And you're actually offline,
what it does is it puts it
into a background process where
basically, when you go
back online, it'll then restart
it up and then go
fetch the articles [INAUDIBLE]
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, that's
brilliant.
PAUL KINLAN: --that you need.
So it's kind of like--
PETE LEPAGE: This is the one--
sorry.
You said it was written
by Paul Lewis.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Paul Lewis and our team wrote
this about three months ago.
We've only just published
it this week.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
That's super cool.
I know for a lot of folks who
are building news reader apps,
who are building apps that
consume a large amount of data
that sits locally on the user's
computers or sits--
that you want to be able to pull
down, this is a really
important thing.
Because otherwise, it's great
to just pull down JSON data.
That's all awesome.
But if you want to pull images,
you want to pull
video, you want to pull any
binary data, you can
base 64 encode it.
But that adds, what, I think
it's like 30%, if I remember
right, to the download size.
Plus storage size, plus it's
just a pain in the butt to
encode and decode.
This means it works.
And with all those caching
features, that's pretty slick.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
It's pretty cool.
The other thing, as well, that
he does, he's got this idea
for a manifest.
And you can host the manifest
on a server.
And what will happen is if you
request that manifest, it will
go and get the manifest, get the
list of images and assets
that you need.
And then you can use it so you
can proactively cache things
in a WebWork or in
the background.
Or use an alarm to wake your
application up at 7:00 in the
morning, go get the manifest,
and then download all of the
stuff ready for it to be
consumed later on.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, perfect.
PAUL KINLAN: There's actually a
whole lot more stuff in this
than we've got, actually, even
the time just tell you now.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, we should
definitely cover this
come the new year.
This is really powerful.
PAUL KINLAN: We only launched it
last week, and we're still
doing a whole lot of stuff.
There's a couple of bugs, a
couple of issues that we want
to try and solve.
So let me just show you the
next two pieces of code.
We have this one here,
which is data source,
which is on the image.
This is just basically a
data attribute where
we encode the source.
And then what happens
is the framework--
It doesn't do it just yet.
But when it detects an image
inside the page that's got a
data source attribute, the idea
is it'll be able to say,
you know what, I need to go
and queue that to go and
request it.
It doesn't do that quite now.
You have to programmatically
go and request the image.
But it's only two or three
lines of code.
It's not too much.
But we want to get it so that
you can just drop an image
into the page, and all the
sudden, it starts to work.
The really cool thing about this
as well, you can specify
placeholder images.
So you might have--
say you were the "New York
Times" or someone like that.
You might want to put your logo
inside a special image,
which is always displayed
until the actual
image asset comes in.
So there's a couple of things
you can do around that.
But if we look here, these,
like, four or five lines of
code here, this is literally
all I need to actually make
the requests to the
remote service.
So I basically detect
an image in the DOM.
I say, go and get me a remote
image and add it to the queue.
And autoStart, so it will
automatically get the image.
And then the system will just
work out what to do, because I
passed an element object into
the remote image object.
It will then basically go and
say, you know, once I've got
the image, I'll go and attach it
to the actual image itself
so it's displayed.
If it's only cached in the file
system, it will just go
and display that cached
version as well.
So it's pretty cool.
And we're going to try and get
it so you don't even have to
have these two lines of code.
But if you really want to kind
of manage that yourself in
your own process, then that
should be completely possible
for you to do as well.
PETE LEPAGE: Nice.
PAUL KINLAN: And that's
actually all the code.
Most of the actual change in
the project was actually me
removing code.
PETE LEPAGE: Nice.
So this saved a good chunk of
code then and made things
easier for you to use.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, exactly.
And the actual app itself
right now uses it.
So the Chrome News App
is using this.
There is a bug here where if we
request this image twice,
it goes blank.
So we can see a couple of the
images are white out.
But we can fix that.
That should be pretty cool.
But I encourage everyone to
go and check it out and
see what it's like.
So it's pretty cool.
PETE LEPAGE: I may actually
have to go
play with this myself.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I added this in last week.
So I thought it would
be good to show
you guys what's happening.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, definitely.
PAUL KINLAN: Do you want to
go onto my next app, or--
PETE LEPAGE: Actually,
Louis, can we get the
questions link put up?
And I want to show one of the
apps that I did for some of
the GDL stuff.
And then we'll pop
back over to you.
So one of the things that with
all of these GDL sessions that
we have, is you'll notice
there's those lower thirds
that get created and put
on all the bottoms.
And they're pretty
much consistent.
They say the show name and the
link to the particular thing.
And oh, look, there's
my name down there.
Well in doing those kinds of
things, every time we did
that, we always has open up,
like, Photoshop, or you had to
open up some kind of
graphic editor.
You had to go in, you'd make
a change, save that one.
Make the change, save
the next one.
And it really got to be
a pain to go and do.
So one of the things that I
wanted to do is try and make
that simpler for me and simpler
for all of the people
who are doing these
GDL things.
I was like, well how
do I do that
using images and graphics?
And as I was thinking
about it.
I was like, well, I guess what I
could do is I could create a
bunch of divs and
do it that way.
So that was one option.
But then the other thing, I was
like, well, I've got this
stuff as transparent
PNGs to begin with.
So I could use a canvas, go
place everything on, apply the
text that I want just using the
draw text in canvas, and
then save it as a PNG.
So I went and wrote this app.
So I'll bring my app up.
And Louis, if we can bring
my app up on screen.
You'll see that--
let me get rid of this so that
we don't have this guy up.
And I guess we don't need my end
of the world app anymore.
So we've got this GDL lower
third generator.
So basically, what it lets me
do is, I can go and type in
name of the show I want.
So hey, we're Chrome Apps.
And I can put in my name,
so Pete LePage.
If I want to center something,
I can put a
bunch of other names.
So on this one I want Pete and
I want Paul, so I separate
them with semicolons.
I can put in all of the links
to our moderator--
everything.
I can choose what different
styles I want.
And then what I did was,
it just uses--
I created a generator call that
goes in, generates each
individual PNG.
And then it saves those PNGs
as transparent PNGs.
And then I used really cool
zip JavaScript library, so
that when I go and hit Generate
here, it gives me
that ability to download.
So I'll save it here
on my desktop.
And here in a sec--
OK, well, it won't save it
to my desktop this time.
Let's try that once more.
Save, desktop, there we go.
Is it hiding on my desktop
somewhere?
All right.
Here, I'll do it this way.
Desktop.
There it is.
So sure enough, there's
the ZIP file.
If I open that up, there's
all my downloads files.
And now, I've suddenly got all
of my lower thirds generated
so that I don't have to go and
recreate every one every
single time.
It's a quick, easy way for me
to be able to do these.
So if you're looking at ways to
create graphics or create
images, this is another tool
where if you're just having to
consistently redo things over
and over again, this was a
really easy way to be
able to do this.
I was talking to Louis
yesterday.
I was showing him the app.
He was like, that's awesome.
But I need one that's just
a nice simple one--
and I didn't tell it to create
this, but like where it just
has the lower third
without any names.
So I went in, added a
quick one of those.
And now we have an easy way
that we can generate those
lower thirds without having
to do anything crazy.
So Paul, I'll pass it
back over to you.
And you can show you next one.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, cool.
So this one is from--
well, let me get his
name, actually.
Anyway, I'll get
it in a minute.
But there's a third-party
developer, who has actually
done some really cool stuff.
He's tried to make his
own application.
And he's uploaded
it to the store.
It's called Clean CSS.
I think the best thing to
do is we'll try and get
the link later on.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
We can add the links.
We'll do a post after today's
show, as well as I'll try and
add the comments to the YouTube
video, if you want to
check those out.
PAUL KINLAN: It's pretty nice.
You do this thing, and you
put this in, and--
MALE SPEAKER: Paul, before you
continue, is it easier that
you could bump that font up?
I know it's going to be
hard for our viewers
to check that out.
PAUL KINLAN: So this is actually
a problem we've got
inside-- generally inside Chrome
Apps, is that it's
actually hard to
bump the font.
So the normal things that
we have don't work.
PETE LEPAGE: That's a
really great point.
I believe there's a
bug filed on that.
If there's not a bug filed,
please go file one--
new.crbug.com--
and let us know so that
we can get it.
And if it's not filed-- or if
it is filed, just make sure
you go star it so that the
developers know that this is a
big thing we want fixed.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
But the general idea behind
this is that it takes some
relatively large CSS files and
then [INAUDIBLE] down into
something that's
a lot smaller.
It's got some very
nice things.
You've got Copy to Clipboard.
And I don't know whether you'll
be able to see this
properly, but press
Copy to Clipboard.
Makes everything smaller, blurs
it out, and then sends
it to the clipboard, which
if we then put it back
in, there we go.
There, it's been minified in.
So it's pretty cool, right?
It's like taking some of your
[INAUDIBLE] data, minified it,
copied it to the clipboard.
And these things you can't quite
do in the normal web
applications.
That's pretty nice.
I'll give you the guy's name
who actually wrote this,
because I've actually
forgotten right now.
PETE LEPAGE: Sorry about that.
PAUL KINLAN: But I want to show
you a couple of other
applications as well, because
they're pretty cool.
We talk about this one quite
a lot, but I use
this all the time.
This is the IRC app
that we've got.
That's also in the store.
If you actually type
in [? "CIRC ?]
Chrome" to Google, you'll be to
find it, because it's been
indexed because people
have linked to it.
But the source is available
on GitHub as well,
and you can do it.
And this is using normal
native sockets.
So Does Liverpool is a place
that I work at in Liverpool.
So let me just say "hello,
everyone." Oh wow, caps lock.
"Hello, everyone." They
might reply with
something nice or not nice.
I don't quite know.
PETE LEPAGE: That's the
wonderful thing
of live to air broadcast.
All right.
Hopefully they'll be nice.
PAUL KINLAN: But it's
pretty cool.
If we go to the actual code, if
we get rid of this little
bit to the side, it's
normal HTML.
The source, as well--
you probably
can't see it very well.
But this is just [INAUDIBLE]
that they chrome.socket.
Let's have a look.
[INAUDIBLE].
That's all there is.
It's pretty crazy.
They've written the API.
They just used a normal
socket interface.
It's no more than just normal
basic JavaScript.
It's pretty nice.
PETE LEPAGE: Nice.
PAUL KINLAN: So I have
another app.
Should we show another app?
PETE LEPAGE: So let's
show one more app.
And then we have a couple
questions in our queue.
So we'll take those questions.
And we'll wrap up for the
day and go from there.
PAUL KINLAN: So it's going
to be pretty cool.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
I like cool.
PAUL KINLAN: So this is a
pretend service that I wrote.
It's a Google shortener.
So basically this was actually
for something that you were
doing with the links.
You were manually going through
and shortening the
links and everything.
It's that I wanted to integrate
with the actual--
what's it called?
The API?
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, that thing,
that API thing, right.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I
wanted to integrate
with the API for Google.
And I think last week, we talked
about the Identity API.
And the Identity API, at the
time, was only third-party
services and not Google-based
services.
And that's because we hadn't
exposed the actual admin
interface view inside
the API console.
A-ha.
Evening, Liverpool.
Liverpool, at least.
So anyway, we hadn't
exposed that.
It's really--
brand new announcement, first to
hear it if you're watching
this right now, is that you
can actually go to your
Developer Console and choose or
create a brand new client
ID for all the Google
Services.
So Google authentications should
work, [? as far as I ?]
know.
I have yet to try it.
Because even though this is a
Google service, I actually
just use normal third-party
authentication flow.
So let me just prove
that this works.
PETE LEPAGE: I just want to
say that again, because I
think that's a really cool
fact and feature.
You just used the normal
third-party authentication
features to access Google
APIs, because the Google
authentication stuff wasn't
quite there and still may be a
little not quite ready
for prime time.
But the third-party
auth stuff is.
That's pretty sick.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
It's pretty cool.
So I'll shortened the URL.
And it should appear.
There it is at the bottom.
That's the short URL
we just created.
And yeah, there's a whole
load more stuff.
I only made this in
a couple hours.
But a lot of it was me just
trying to make sure the Google
APIs were working with
authentication and the
Identity API.
And just because it's built off
the back of OAuth 2, it
means it pretty much
works straightaway.
I know that we do some extra
things with refresh tokens and
some other stuff.
But I've just chosen to ignore
all that, because actually,
what's happening behind the
scenes here is that even
though the authentication
didn't work, it tries to
authenticate every
single request.
So I'm not storing
an access token.
I'm getting a brand new
one every single time.
So should we have a quick look
if I can get it up properly?
PETE LEPAGE: I've got a couple
questions up on our moderator.
So why don't I start with
those while you pull
some of them up.
PAUL KINLAN: I'll get the
console up so I can show you.
Can I just show you how
you actually go
about creating one?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: You use the
normal Google APIs--
code.google.com/apis/console--
to create your project.
And then you do something quite
simple, where if you go
to API Access, you create
an OAuth 2 client ID.
Give it a name-- so
test x, maybe.
That's a good name.
And you normally have a list of
options-- web application,
service account, and installed
application.
Well, it turns out Chrome
applications are actually
installed applications and not
pure web applications that
live on the web.
So you press the installed
application, you select Chrome
Application.
And you put your extension
ID in.
So if you had your
extension ID--
I'm going to say it's that.
Hopefully this will work.
It's just a random one.
PETE LEPAGE: I always
love random.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
It didn't work.
But you basically put in
your own extension ID.
Let's do that one for now.
So this should work.
Create client ID.
And then we've got the client
ID and application
secret that we need.
And that's all you have
to do to start
accessing Google Services.
And you can select the
list of services
that you want to access.
I would normally select
Google Link Shortener.
And I would be able to access it
straight away, and I'd use
the Google authentication.
Now, I just want to say, the
interesting thing about the
Google authentication, why
it's different than third
party, is that when the user
installs the application, we
can prompt them to say, this
application wants to access
your Google Docs or your Google
Drive, and those types
of things, which we can't do
because we don't know how
every other third-party
API works.
So through Google Services,
you can get that installed
properly, which is important,
which is why you need that
special ID.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
All right.
Well, let's pop over
to our questions.
We've got about three or four
minutes left before we need to
wrap up for today.
So our first question about from
Adam in San Francisco.
He wants to know, should
chrome.runtime.lastError be
checked on every call that
uses a call back?
How should Chrome runtime
last error be used?
I'm working on a library that
interfaces with a Chrome app
via Dart, and most of this
is wrapped in futures.
Paul, what's your
take on this?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
You have to check last error.
I mean, the last error is pretty
much always populated
from the last error
that happened.
So if one of your API methods
failed when you called it,
then you should check
last error.
We don't have the onSuccess
and onFailure that you'd
expect from, say, a normal
purely web application.
We don't have futures, either.
That's not to say that we
couldn't wrap it up and have a
JavaScript API which makes it a
little bit easier, that kind
of knows when the last error did
occur and not to kind of
overwrite it.
Because basically, the
last error stays
populated all the time.
So if you make a request to
a Chrome-specific API.
It could be three requests
down, later on, where you
actually go and check
last error.
And oh, it's errored.
Well, has it errored?
Was it that API?
You don't quite know.
So you do have to check.
But it might be better if we
kind of come up with a better
interface in the library.
And maybe we kind of test that
with the JavaScript shim to
start off with.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
PAUL KINLAN: Because honestly,
it's a little bit awkward
trying to interface with
index.db and then integrate
with the media gallery API.
And these are two things which
are different APIs,
essentially.
And they've got different
semantics for
errors and call backs.
So we might have to write a
little JavaScript shim to make
that a little bit easier.
But right now, you just
have to check.
The simplest thing is
you have to check.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
So James from Ontario--
my hometown, or, I guess,
my home province--
wants to know, do Chrome apps
run agnostic to the operating
system, or are there
cross-platform issues that he
needs to keep in mind?
Should I bother testing on
Windows and Linux if he's
developing on Mac?
Can I safely assume that
my app will be
fabulous across the board?
And that's a really
great question.
I would say in the 99% case,
your app is going to be
fabulous across the board.
There's a couple places where I
think you do want to spend a
little bit of time testing.
And that's going to
be things like
serial, USB, and Bluetooth.
Those are the three that just
come to mind for me that I
just want to do a little bit of
extra testing, just because
the stacks in those particular
places are
a little bit different.
Paul, are you--
go ahead.
PAUL KINLAN: Sorry.
No, I was going to say
the same thing.
I agree with you completely
there, is that the actual
render and the basic things
that you'd expect to work
should just work.
PETE LEPAGE: You're
running Chrome.
PAUL KINLAN: You
should never--
yeah, you're running Chrome.
That's never an excuse
not to test.
But the assumption should be
that it's going to be a lot
easier and a lot easier to
kind of test across them.
And like you said, the
differences are
the hardware APIs.
So for instance, Bluetooth
might not work on Windows
because we don't have access
to the stack, whereas we've
got better access to the
stack on Chrome OS.
I know we've seen some bugs on
actual Chromium Apps, made a
list as well, where the serial
port didn't work because we
haven't got the regular
expression right to filter out
the actual com ports
for serial ports.
We haven't got that right
for Windows, so it
didn't work at all.
So those are the type
of things that
you'd have to check.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
But the point will be, we want
to get it as close as possible
so that you don't have
to worry about that.
So we have a little
bit of work to do.
But we think you guys
should test as well.
So I'll go for a question
from Belgium next.
Linux, in the base plug-in for
playing games or video on
Facebook, is sometimes
it works--
you know, I'm actually going to
come back to the question.
Because I'm not quite sure I
understand your question.
PAUL KINLAN: I think there's
a plug-in that
doesn't work on Linux.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: The only think
I can say is, file a bug.
He's using Chrome for
Linux 11 or 12?
We're at 25.
So file a bug.
I'm not exactly sure whether it
will get fixed, because I
don't believe we backport that
far to these places.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
We might go back a couple--
PAUL KINLAN: That's the whole
point of the auto update
system is that we love to
maintain [INAUDIBLE]
versions, at least.
Should we get on to the
Airborne question?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, sure.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So does the Identity API support
all the visions of
OAuth 1.0, 1.0a?
It's a really good question.
So the thing is that
the Google API
endpoint uses OAuth 2.
And we've coded it to work
with just OAuth 2.
The third-party format, or the
third-party authentication
launcher, essentially-
it's agnostic.
So we don't actually care, in
theory, about the type of
authentication you're using.
You could use some weird
authentication system which
returns a session ID in the
query parameter, which you can
then take out for your admin
panel to push into your app,
and a whole load
of other stuff.
You can do those type
of things as well.
And the idea behind that was if
you have OAuth 1 and OAuth
1a applications is that
in theory, you should
be able to do it.
I haven't tested it, because I
don't like OAuth 1, and I've
wanted to stay away from
it [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: I think we might
have one person who likes it.
And his or her name
would be Airborne.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
But the interesting thing is
that normally what happens is
that the authentication APIs in
most third-party services,
they can't redirect to anything
that's not HTTP and
HTTPS URLs.
So every single app at the
moment has a Chrome hype and
extension scheme in the actual
URL, which you won't be able
to redirect to.
And Instagram kind of
worked last week.
But that was kind of a fortunate
coincidence.
If you look at the Facebook--
sorry, if
you look at the friend--
Foursquare application--
[INAUDIBLE].
If you look at the Foursquare
application that we've got on
our sample repository as well,
that uses OAuth 2, but it's
using this redirect to a special
domain that we own.
So basically what is, I think
it's your extension ID dot
Chromium app dot org.
And that's going to redirect the
URL, and you can send the
third-party services that use
OAuth 1 or OAuth 1a back
towards inside your
application.
PETE LEPAGE: And we'll
redirect it for you
automatically.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
We'll do the redirect
from there.
It might not work very well.
I would test it.
And if you have any feedback
about these
things, let me know.
I will kind of get it working.
But the majority of people
are moving to OAuth 2.
And OAuth 2 works very well.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Well, Paul, I think that's all
the time we have for today.
Thanks for joining
me from London.
I hope you have a really
great holiday.
PAUL KINLAN: Sorry, can
I just interrupt?
James Doyle, he did
the CSS Cleaner.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
James Doyle from Ontario.
That was his question.
All right.
Well, James, thank you.
So I want to thank everybody
for joining us this week.
We're going to be back
in the new year.
We'll probably start back--
I want to say it'll be the
second week of January with
our Chrome Apps Office Hours.
We've got some really exciting
stuff planned for 2013--
things like push messaging,
notifications.
We've got great new
authentication stuff.
We have a ton of stuff that
we're really excited about
that we think you're going to
be really excited about.
So thanks for joining us.
Paul, thank you.
PAUL KINLAN: Thank
you, very much.
PETE LEPAGE: And I can't
wait to see you
all in the new year.
Thank you very much.
PAUL KINLAN: Bye bye.